c'était comme une parenthèse dans cette
actualité violente la quatrième édition
de l'électro pull Party a remporté un
franc succès samedi soir à Blois la
piscine agglo a accueilli 1200
participants et a battu son record de
l'année dernière Clémence d'OSC faisait
partie des convives
les images parlent d'elles-mêmes
l'électro poule partie de Blois a mis le
feu
l'ambiance est montée crescendo avec une
ouverture des portes à 16h le plus de ce
festival la possibilité de faire
trempette dans le bassin extérieur de la
piscine en écoutant plus de 8 heures de
sept électro
nous c'est ce qu'on adore on va au
Pays-Bas on va partout pour faire ça on
s'est dit à moi au pays direct c'est
parti
principalement en artiste que j'avais
très envie de voir et qui
miraculeusement se retrouve là
à peine 2 heures de route des fois
clairement ouais
pour cette 4e édition 8 artistes se sont
succédés parmi eux des pointures
internationales le tout dans une
organisation millimétrée gage de
confiance envers les institutions
partenaires de l'événement ils adorent
le concept ça fait venir aussi pour un
nouveau public 50% à peu près du public
vient hors du département donc pour le
coup c'est voilà et d'ouvrir aussi un
public hyper familial des enfants des
jeunes des moins jeunes et voilà donc le
pot c'est tout béfique le festival
affiché complet avec 1500 places vendues
pas d'orage ni de soleil de plomb ce
soir là l'endroit le plus chaud c'était
la scène